yes president Donald Trump caused yet
another controversy at the weekend by
calling the city of Baltimore
a rotten rodent infested mess critics
say he launched the attack because of a
black politician from the city Elijah
Cummings had slammed Trump's policy on
migrants at the border some have
described Trump's comments as racist
GWS Oliver sollett has been to the city
to hear what some of the residents feel
about this latest focus on their
hometown the city of Baltimore faces
many problems and one has been there for
many years
West Baltimore which is prone to crime
and violence and where the streets are
in decay
one of the last homicides happened just
here a few days ago with more than 300
people murdered last year there's no
doubt that Baltimore is one of the most
violent cities in North America but as
this make it a rat and Road and infested
mess as President Trump says a series of
inflammatory tweets from the White House
is Baltimore's latest problem president
Trump calling the city a very dangerous
and filthy place worst in the USA and
says no human being would want to live
there president Trump's statements are
wrong they represent a political attack
and a lack of understanding regarding
the dynamics of Baltimore the dynamics
of crime a city with a black population
of more than 60% some feel insulted by
the president's rhetoric but others say
there's some truth to what he says he's
right about some parts but like others
like if you haven't been here you can't
really say anything about it especially
if you're not helping the city he's
right about what he said it may have
been a ways in it but that's Donald
Trump he says it like it is I think of
people who are insulted are absolutely
justified and being insulted because he
has no idea what he's talking about but
that's the case of everything with his
attack president Trump is taking on some
of his most vocal critics congressman
Elijah Cummings who represents parts of
Baltimore in
yes they are human beings City
Councilman Leon Pinkett says Trump's
attacks on Baltimore are above all
political gamesmanship congressman
Cummings has been doing an exceptional
job as he chairs the Oversight Committee
in Congress and the the reality is he is
and as a result of his work I'm he's
shedding light on a lot of issues that
are directly responded they the
president is directly responsible for
and when we talk about our border policy
when we talk about the the the treatment
of immigrants a good reason for the
president to take on Cummings and his
congressional district even if that
doesn't improve the situation in West
Baltimore